people ask me what's this one of the
keys to relationship physical intimacy
it's a box you better be checking
if you want to create intensity
it demands risk taking doing new things
outside of your comfort zone a little
bit more on the edge
do not keep score because you are
poisoning all of the relationships that
you start
wanna be happy build a life not just a
[Music]
business
i believe hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you
know there's something more inside you
two you have michael jordan level genius
at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the five habits
for a successful and happy relationship
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with habit number
one show an active appreciation with mel
robbins
well i just i mean he does a lot of my
back office stuff for me
and i'm always waiting for him to help
me and you know like my coaches are like
you're fine you can do it but i'm like
you don't understand and he's the
support but he's not
like moving fast tonight the reason why
he's not is because he doesn't
understand either
how critical it is that he supports you
he doesn't feel like he matters
probably that's it bingo
if you were to leave here and do nothing
but
anytime you oh my god i so appreciate
that you just did that you have no idea
thank you thank you thank you honey
if you were to bring him more into the
business not as in
selling right but cheering for him right
and making sure he understands that
every stride you make is only because
of what he's doing back at home right
that will change how he behaves
i i know it because i have the part of
our company that's out in the spotlight
my husband runs the books runs legal
runs operations runs hr and is also the
point parent while i travel
and so it'd be very easy to feel
unappreciated
because his role is not visible i go out
of my way
to snapchat at him to acknowledge him
to elevate him to thank him to make him
feel appreciated because we that's
what's missing
if somebody's not motivated on your team
whether it's your spouse or somebody
else
they don't feel appreciated okay that's
why habit number two
practice physical intimacy with ed
mylett
i have a philosophy about long-term
relationships that isn't discussed very
often
so for those of my friends that are in
one that's i don't know how long
but for some people long terms a year
right but for those of us that are in
long-term relationships i get asked
often on shows hey what are one of the
what are one of the keys that i would
not
normally hear about that
create a relationship that is still
doing what you said earlier which is so
wonderful where there really is this
observation there's separation there's
growth happening
and so there's all these things they're
saying a long time be honest with one
another
you know be trustworthy make sure you're
communicating
one of the things that i find with my
friends and i who have had
long-term really good relationships
is physical intimacy still and real
attraction to one another physically if
you're you know everyone says i want to
marry my best friend which you do
but you have a lot of friends and you
need to be married to all of them and
one of the things i see in relationships
is they start out where there's this
physical chemistry and i know
relationships ebbs and flow i'm not just
talking about sex
i'm referring to physical touching and
intimacy when i was dating christiana
her dad was older than her mother and it
was his second marriage his first wife
had died
of cancer and often times in second
marriages i see people
kind of know the second time around
maybe the mistakes they made the first
time his case his wife had actually
passed away
but i would date when i would date her i
would often pick her up
and when you'd walk up to their home
their front door and i'd knock to come
get her you could see into their living
room
and my family didn't have this my
parents have their own dynamic
but i would i would go to the front door
and more times than not
matthew more times than not not every
time on a saturday night i'd come to
pick up my girlfriend for a date i could
look into the living room and the tv
would be off
i get emotional because he's passed away
but they'd be slow dancing
wow and at an advanced age wow they just
slow dance in the living room together
now i don't know if that led to more
than that in the bedroom afterwards but
they had
real physical intimacy they weren't just
friends they were lovers
in every sense physical lovers that
doesn't always actually mean
but people ask me what's this one of the
keys relationship physical intimacy it's
a box you better be checking there's got
to be that
touching and that physical attraction to
have a passionate
relationship i love the book by my
brother evan carmichael built to serve
you guys this is the kind of thing you
get in this book
most people wake up and drive to a job
they hate think about your five closest
friends
are they happy do they live their lives
with purpose do you
we put on a fake front for what we want
people to see and think about us
but the reality is most people aren't
happy we're lost
we settle you can't be happy if you
don't know your purpose and then he goes
on to explain how to do that
you guys should get this book built to
serve by my dear friend evan carmichael
habit number three do new things with
your partner
doing new things with your partner that
if you do the things that you enjoy
that's really nice that's comfortable
that's cozy that solidifies the
friendship
but if you want to create intensity
it it demands risk-taking doing new
things
outside of your comfort zone a little
bit more on the edge
how often should we be doing new things
with our intimate partner
i think as often i mean look the answer
to this is very simple
often enough but not too often that you
become chaotic and you dysregulate
right now you're asking me a systemic
question this is true for an individual
a relationship or a company if you
don't change or grow you fossilize
and you die if you change too much
too fast no stability there's no
stability you go chaotic and you
dysregulate
so how often it depends on where you are
at in your life
are you the two of you do you have kids
do you have little ones do you have
aging parents are you taking care of
somebody what else is going on here
we'll tell you if this is a period where
you need more stability
or if this is a period where it's time
to go and be curious and explore and
discover and go into the world
and launch habit number four be willing
to compromise with sarah blakely and
jesse itzler
when you get married there's a lot of
things that you never considered before
your philosophy around parenting your
philosophy around food
you're possibly around what schools you
want to go to on how you want to
discipline your kids
there's a lot of of scenarios that you
never think about
and it's just you know you have to have
a partner
that is flexible and you have to be
flexible
in those main buckets because they'll
tear apart a marriage
they'll tear it apart man you have to be
aligned in those
in those buckets and there's more and
aligned or willing to compromise
right because it's a lot of compromising
but you guys are both likes
like driven high achieving
stuck to your like mindset type of
people because it's what got you to
where you are
what was the hardest thing for you guys
to be flexible about
each one of you to be totally honest
food
because you're a vegan we come from
different schools of thought
you eat meat right sir and by the way
louis food's not so easy because
i don't know the last time i checked you
needed to live and the last time i
checked you have three meals a day 21 a
week
so if you're not aligned and the energy
is like this you know wow food is the
the biggest challenge for you guys well
it's something that i'm deeply
passionate about
yeah and um and very well read
and have very strong opinions on and you
speak about publicly all the time about
right so it's the hardest thing for me
to
to to budge and move wow um
and sarah's been very patient in this
and we've worked we've we've
really come really far very far we've
actually basically solved
what could have been a really big
problem really well if
anything is a big problem if you let it
bubble and escalate
and then resent anything so how did you
solve the
we compromised with the media here we we
compromised we worked at it
we worked at it we invested one
compromise is
with the kids don't eat red meat but we
do turkey and chicken
so that was like a big kind of in the
middle for us
you know i i eat these things in
moderation but
it was important to me to kind of my
biggest thing was i didn't want to
focus on food in our family i didn't
want it to be a big subject i didn't
want the children to feel limited or too
controlled around food and so it's very
difficult when you're with someone who's
uber controlling around fear well whose
intentions
are are pure and he wants to live a long
life healthy
his philosophies make a lot of sense i
mean let's totally it
it's not like he's so i've seen every
documentary on veganism
yeah so it's just it's just was this was
a messy bucket for us but we
we continue to talk it out and work it
out and we've
we've really come a long way on that and
habit number five the last one before
very special bonus clip
is nurture the relationship with jordan
harbinger
as a friend reaching out and saying hey
i'm watching a book in a few months
would love to do the show also
here's a bunch of other things happening
the reason this is important
is most people don't build these
relationships before they need them
and these are the same people that would
they obviously have a spare tire in the
trunk of their car so if they get a flat
on the highway
they're taken care of but if they want
to build a relationship
they're not thinking about digging that
well before they're thirsty
so they're only looking at what help
they need
when they need it and that is a huge
mistake you have to dig the well before
you're thirsty and you have to give
without the attachment to
getting something in return so when
people want to reach out
stop thinking about what's in it for you
start thinking about
only what's in it for other people and
if you don't worry about what's in it
for you
you will find opportunities that come
later down the line
and to sort of illustrate this when i
moved to la i had a toothache
and it started to get more and more
painful and it really was starting to
just dig
into my brain i couldn't think i didn't
have a car i moved from new york
this is pre uber i didn't have dental
insurance because i was 27 and you know
who cares about your teeth right you
think about those later
i'll get new ones and so i started to
desperately call dentists
and they were like uh look i don't take
new patients or
i i can see you in a week go to the er
if you have a toothache and i'm thinking
a week i haven't slept you know this
thing is killing me
so i posted on facebook and obviously i
didn't have my privacy settings set
correctly because a random stranger
filled in the comment and said my aunt's
a dentist near you do you want me to
give her a call
and i said sure yeah so i went to his
aunt the next morning before they
officially opened got that thing drilled
the hell out
got it filled she didn't overcharge me i
send this guy a message
thank you so much he goes no problem man
i
i don't know what you do i heard you
have some show that my friend likes
but i'm glad you got your tooth taken
care of and i said let me know if
there's anything i can do he said well
i'm a graphic designer but i'm working
at a cafe right now as a barista i would
love to just not make another cup of
coffee again and i said well
i don't have any work for you but i'll
keep my ear to the ground he said
whatever you can do
no problem i don't expect you to give me
a job four days later
another entrepreneur friend of mine she
writes me and says my
web guys are blowing it i keep firing
them who can create
good branding for me i said i've never
worked with this guy but here's a
portfolio
he's a nice person that's really all i
can say that guy got a full-time job
as far as i know still works there years
later designing
websites and templates and themes and
branding for this woman's company
because he helped me find a dentist on
facebook
so if he'd been thinking how do i get a
job he would never have made
that introduction to a dentist because
the connection the nexus is unclear the
opportunity lie
over the horizon but since he was
helping without the attachment or
expectation of anything in return
he ended up finding an opportunity
through me that i didn't know about
and that he didn't know about but you
won't find those
unless you are constantly reaching out
digging the well before you're thirsty
and giving without that expectation
of anything in return and last but not
least
people keep score now and this is bad do
not keep score and what i mean by that
is
if you interview someone and
then you help them you drive into the
airport
they don't owe you anything but people
in our heads we create these covert
contracts
and the reason they're called covert
contracts is because it exists in my
head but it doesn't exist in yours
so we've got this weird agreement where
i drive you to the airport and then i
pick you up and i drive you again and i
pick you up and you're like hey jordan's
such a good friend
he's always got you know he's always got
time for me he wakes up early so he
doesn't mind driving me to the airport
for my super early flights
and in my head i go one day i'm gonna
make tom have me on his show and i'm
gonna sell my
magical weight loss formula and then one
day i pitched this to you and you go
uh not totally a fit for what we're
doing here at impact theory
i'll help you in other ways if i can and
then in my head i go
you son of a right i'm mad at you now
because you broke the deal that i
created in my head you broke the con
the contract the covert contract so i'm
starting to be passive aggressive i'm
angry with you i can't change my
behavior even if it's a little
subconscious
i'm a little bit colder towards you and
our friendship gradually dies
why did this happen you didn't do
anything wrong
i created an agreement in my head where
you started to owe me something
and you didn't reciprocate and that made
me angry
people do this we do this subconsciously
we think other people owe us
if someone creates opportunities for you
you introduce them to a bunch of people
you help them out a lot
that's it there's no agreement to
reciprocate now if someone helps you
you should reciprocate where you can if
someone doesn't reciprocate towards you
though
do not keep score because you are
poisoning all of the relationships that
you start
because you don't know how that person
might be able to help you in the future
you don't want to create a bad
reputation for yourself
and you will spend years thinking this
person
they're a one-sided friend they're not a
friend this person didn't do this thing
for me
and years later down the line you just
have no idea what could have been
because you're poisoning all of your own
relationships now i've got a special
bonus clip that i think you're going to
enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video
and what is your plan of action that
you're going to execute this week
to make some immediate momentum happen
when you just get
motivated and watch a video you have a
35
chance of following through that's what
the science says but
when you write down what time what day
what place you're actually going to
execute when you create the plan
you have a 91 chance of following
through
and i want that for you and when you
commit to people publicly
you increase your chances even more of
actually doing it
so i want to know what your single
biggest takeaway from this video was
and your specific plan of action
to actually get the result you're after
let me know put it down in the comments
below
because i want to celebrate you i think
if you have a partner who doesn't
support
your business you're either going to
lose your business you're going to lose
your partner
it's really hard to be mission driven
and want to have a successful company
and be in a relationship with somebody
who doesn't support you
i think there's four buckets that people
fall into
two of them are negative and two of them
are positive the two on the negative
side
you have a partner who just absolutely
hates what you're doing
you have a partner who just doesn't
believe in what you're doing they hate
it
they think you should quit they think
it's tearing down the family
they just don't want you to do anything
with related to that business
and that really sucks as a place to be
you can't continue on
with your business and your relationship
you have to figure out a way to make it
happen you support them
support them first if you are supporting
them in their career and their ambitions
and their drive and what they're looking
for
you're much more likely to get support
back on you if you were just expecting
support 24 7 but you're not giving it
first
it's really hard so if you want to to
get it back
you want to receive start by giving and
so
they may not want to be an entrepreneur
that may not be how you support them
but could you support them in their
career could you support them in their
friendships could you support them in
your relationship like what are they
after what are their goals what are
their aspirations what do they need help
with
do they just need somebody to come home
and listen to them for half an hour when
they walk in the door what is it what
does support look like for them
not your version of it you know what you
want
what's their version of it and how can
you support them in accomplishing
their goals their ambitions their
aspirations you support them first
and then you'll get a little more
support on your written i promise
[Music]
if you want to change your life in the
next 30 days for free
check out my training right here below
or if you want to learn how to transform
your relationships with tony robbins
check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy them continue to believe
and i'll see you there